[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
closing ceremony of the st. Louis rapid
and blitz an event an inaugural event
that simply broke all records and will
go down as one of the most famous events
in chess history
I'm Maurice Ashley we're here at the
world chess Hall of Fame I want to thank
them for hosting our event and this
truly was indeed special there are some
summers that you remember maybe it was a
fantastic vacation or special someone
that you met well this summer had it all
and we had simply a whole summer of
chess beginning with a match of the
Millennials the strongest young players
around the country challenging the
strongest young players here in the
United States we continued with a sink
filled Cup where one magnus carlsen
joined us the best players in the world
regale dust with fighting chess one by
maxime beaugeois graphic hosed out with
this event the st. Louis rapid and blitz
won by Levon Aronian in fine style and
of course also we had ultimate moves
which showed how much fun chess is the
passion that we have for the game a
little bit of trash-talking by the
players as well it was absolutely a
fantastic summer we're glad to close it
out here and for more remarks we welcome
the executive director of the Chess Club
and scholastic and well let me get that
right Chess Club and scholastic Center
st. Louis Tony rich Thank You Maurice
I'd like to begin my remarks as I do
most times by thanking the two people
without whom none of this would be
possible their vision the resources the
strategic direction and the passion for
chess and what we're doing here is
really what has made all this possible
dr. Jeanne and Rex Sinquefield thank you
of course there's a people to thank of
fleischman-hillard is our PR firm kylie
and mark worked with them very closely
to make sure everything happens
silverback and spectrum studios led by
randy singh field i mean their crew is
responsible for all of the video work
and all the wonderful viewership numbers
that we've had online I would be remiss
of course if I didn't thank my staff you
know I always say they are the ones that
make me look good
it's amazing how hard they all work and
it's because they share our passion for
what we're doing and they're really
invested in the future of st. Louis in
the future of chess in America so it's
been a wonderful experience Shannon
Bailey my counterpart here at the world
chess Hall of Fame even a Carla Nakamura
I mean really thank them all so the
grand chessboard started as a
partnership between way back in the day
was Norway chess London chess classic in
here in st. Louis for the Sinquefield
cuff it is sense evolved now we have
five events in the grand chest tour we
started everything in Paris and Louvre
in Paris Paris Grantchester lurvin
Louvre in your next move here in st.
Louis over the past three weeks we've
had the Sinquefield Cup and the st.
Louis rabbit and blitz and the grand
chest war wraps up in London this
December with the London chess classic
so that'll be very exciting everyone's
you know fighting hard for the top
honours at the grand chest or and I
think we'll see some exciting chess in
London coming up you know I mentioned
the grand chest or and there are a ton
of people to thank within the grand
chest tour but I'll keep my comments
limited Paris grand chests were
sponsored by Colliers International
Vivendi and dailymotion and then Leuven
is actually sponsored by your next move
which is a charity helping run chess
programs and schools in the area so
they've been excellent partners on this
we're very excited that they're coming
back next year to continue to keep the
grand chest for what it is and help us
grow our technical director at the Grand
Chester is Graham gurgenson who couldn't
be here today but Graham is the one
who's been behind the scenes helping
make sure all of the the details between
the events work seamlessly all of the
players have the information that they
need so we couldn't do all of this
without Graham of course but like I said
the grand chest war really is that the
the premier chest see
is the premier chess sequence of
tournaments throughout the world every
year and it's our goal to continue to
make it better to continue to grow the
chest tour and to continue to provide
more opportunities to spotlight these
amazing chess players let's have a round
of applause for all of them so I
mentioned before we've all got bosses in
this case it's my pleasure to introduce
to you erections boss his wonderful wife
dr. Jeannie Singh field something very
exciting happened today in the ultimate
moves they all smiled and so I get to
introduce Rex congratulations as being
able to beat your son and a few
grandmasters hero there and we have
three nines a former world champion Gary
a long time world champion future world
champions and the one who is never going
to make world champion but is the
godfather of
US chess Rex Sinquefield
well thank you Jeannie you never know I
might surprise you already last year I
treat grandmasters imitating my most
famous move so thanking everybody for
the Grantchester
I want to thank the genius the visionary
in the true inspiration for it
former world champion Garry Kasparov and
of course it's gonna be redundant but
it's worth it to thank Randy and all of
his crew and jennifer yasser maurice and
Verico bian and robert hess with a
tremendous live commentary at King site
and Alejandro and Evette for doing the
commentary in Espanola kingside muchas
gracias which is e miss grats yes yes so
the end I mean the reason we have these
tournaments is because we have Jennifer
yasser and maurice that is the only
reason to have all these events so they
can show how good they are and they are
i say it over and over but i mean they
are the best commentators of any sport
in the world
period
[Applause]
so the grand chester is working around
thinking about the 2018 international
calendar and how to expand the tour and
as we learn these details we will let
you know them as soon as we can and now
it's my pleasure to to thank one of our
public officials we receive enormous
support and encouragement from the
public officials here in st. Louis
first from former mayor slay I think you
all know that every chess event we had
four nine eight or nine years mayor slay
showed up and now we are blessed with
the presence of Steve stinger the county
executive the man in charge of the
entire st. Louis County area and would
you please welcome County Executive
Steve stinger thank you all very much
it's a real pleasure to be here tonight
and thank you Rex for those kind words
it is a pleasure and an honor to speak
once again before some of the world's
greatest chess players and fans and as
you are well aware the st. Louis region
is the chess capital of the world
and this bears repeating in light of the
large number of visitors who have
attended previous chess tournaments here
it's easy to see how the st. Louis area
benefits from its standing as the
epicentre of chess there's the economic
factor the Chess Club plays host to ten
major tournaments every year and one
event alone the 2017 US Championships
held at the Chess Club in March
generated an estimated 1 million dollars
for our local economy which is
incredible and then there is the ripple
effect of being the destination for
world-class chess many of the many of
the game's top players now live in the
st. Louis region this of course adds to
our reputation as having a skilled
innovative an intelligent population
which in turn makes the st. Louis region
an attractive place for businesses to
recruit and hire fantastic workers again
I appreciate the opportunity to
participate in tonight's rapid and blitz
ceremony and I expend my special I
extend my special thanks
- Jeannie and Rexach field for their
sponsorship of this tournament and for
all they do to promote chess and our
region thank you very much thank you
Steve well you would not have a chess
tournament if you didn't have chess
players and these are among the greatest
chess players to ever pick up a chess
piece so may I have the honor of
introducing all our players starting on
this end from Vietnam grandmaster Liam
Lee from the Czech Republic grandmaster
David Navarro from Russia grandmaster
Sergei Kuryakin also from Russia
grandmaster Yan Nippon the achieve on
the other end from the United States
grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura from india
grandmaster Vishwanath on-on-on from
Cuba Grandmaster Lanier Dominguez from
the United States Grandmaster faggiano
Caruana and I debated who I should
introduce next but in the end the
winners gets rights but I'd like to say
a special thank you to this next person
who without his vision without his
energy without his passion and foresight
none of this would have happened and he
continues to be a great leader in the
world of chess as he does all around the
world his many humanitarian adventures
he continues to want to make sure his
game grows and he decided to come back
out of retirement he had nothing to
prove but he did so for the benefit of
chess the benefit of chess here in st.
Louis please give a very warm hand to
grandmaster xiii world champion Garry
Kasparov
[Applause]
in the winner of the event not only the
winner of this event but the winner of
the trash-talking award as his grace is
charm his ability to stay cool under
pressure has won all our hearts and we
cannot think of a more deserving winner
of this event please give a warm hand to
from Armenia Grand Master Levon Aronian
[Applause]
doing a few questions for the players
I'm gonna start with a newcomer to not
the st. Louis area as he did play a
match here before but Grandmaster
Dominguez you got to change the play in
the Chess Club for the first time tell
us a little bit about your experience
well it was really nice so I wanted to
take this opportunity again to thank the
organizers for inviting me it's always a
pleasure to compete with the best
players in the world and especially this
year because also Gary was playing was
even more special to play so I have I
had the feeling that I could do better
but I guess it's uh it's common for all
players but but still I all in all I
think it was a great experience
thank you another newcomer to the stage
Grand Master Lee Emily what was it like
for you to be able to play not only the
event but against one Gary Kasparov
so I live in this city now I have been
to the Chess Club so many times so I
have seen tournaments every year but
this year is different because I get the
opportunities to play with all the
sovereign masters and it's a great honor
and pleasure to be here to participate
in this big tournament and see so many
Jeff's fans so many strong players so
I'm very thankful for the organizer
especially gin and grace so about Gary
he's definitely one of the best chess
player up on Tam and I always admire him
since I learn playing chess at a young
age so it's a big honor to play him here
and I think it's a great experience for
all of us and hopefully we'll get more
chances to play more tournaments in the
future thank you but who can forget the
epic game I know Gary still remembers
this game against Grandmaster David
navara sorry Gary but it indeed was one
of those battles David what was it like
to be in st. Louis and to be able to
also defeat one Garrick is far play here
thank you for the invitation I could
have played here ok I'm not so happy
about my play because I made too many
mistakes but I played some good games
and oh well it was my more able to play
master Kasparov and but I was really
very lucky in the game I admitted this
but ok I played two better games here
but this this will remain memorable for
me I'm sorry for my English I'm just
nervous
ok
thank you thank you so much the other
players have all spoken I want to make
sure we get an opportunity to our
newcomers well we let you take the stage
Gary you decided to come back out of
retirement I'm still trying to get you
to extend the return we all want to see
it the fans want to see it Gary now that
it is done what are your thoughts about
your experience was a good learning
experience I am I knew it would be tough
challenge and I knew that it seemed very
hard to fight against my new habits and
new algorithms because 12 years I just
you know I lost them I lost touch here I
I think I recollected at some point yeah
it's probably you know just told me to
end the talk too soon one one extra day
could have helped but what I wanted is
just to raise the awareness about the
ground chess tool and also to bring
attention to the to San Luis and that's
that was overachieved
we have record numbers of people
watching it and I think it's important
people are paying attention this is it's
as an ambassador for the game of chess I
I could feel exhilarated for all the
mistakes I made in this tournament and
of course you know this is something
memorable always happens so I will for
the rest of my life I'll have no more a
moment now last night we bumped into the
hotel you were just talking about that
game but all the missed opportunities
some really begins games that I could
have won quite handily first against
LaVon couple of times so but but then
also some of them are bad police made
mistakes you know the
hospitality of Vietnamese colleague
which is blundered rook yes after my
game was navara so there again I
probably equalized at that point but
it's but it's you know it's overall it's
it's I'm I'm quite happy that I just I
did this chance I just took this risk
and it's it's more than you know it's
modern I'm more than rewarded for for
for for all this you know five days of
this mental torture is it indeed the
last time you're gonna play in a
professional competition Never Say Never
so again this this that's what they say
but now one thing is what one thing I
know for sure I get it says I'm you know
I'm protected by amateur status I'm not
a professional player I'm not going to
play anywhere buttons and lose it's very
clear so there because here I feel that
you know I I'm sorry the right place so
we would be building something big it's
many of my dreams that have been
[Music]
coaching over decades now they'd be
realized here so that's why I feel I
feel indebted to so that's why if it
happens which I doubt very much it's it
can happen over here it's it's miracles
and lose thank you for that absolutely
those are great words we are indebted to
you Gary for your vision and we
appreciate all the exposure folks over a
million viewers of both events without a
Gary kiss borrow that doesn't happen he
is indeed a driving force bringing
popularity to chess all over the world
so please give him another warm welcome
for what he does far
[Applause]
and we had a winner LaVon you played
extremely well in this event dominated
in the first day started off slow and
then caught your role at the end your
feelings about the event and keeping
your positive record against Garry
Kasparov it was very very interesting
event I have to say I have to compliment
the organizers for picking the field all
the players all the wildcards are very
competitive competitive and especially
Garrick image was who I could feel that
wants to do very well and he was playing
very exciting chess so I had very
positive feeling from the start and I
think some of the games I was lucky but
generally I mean in such tournament
you're gonna get lucky so and keeping
the good score with Gary well I think I
should give him motivation to come back
and play and play more so I hope this
the fact that he was some good positions
will yes well but motivate him to play
more and of course I cannot say enough
words to thank Rex and Jeanne for their
great contribution to the Sinquefield
Cup and everything that is happening in
this wonderful city
you mentioned you mentioned that you
wanted to make sure you raised your
rating and show people that you're a
good Blitzen rapid player mission
accomplished
yeah I mean there can only be one
mission but first you need to get step
by step so I like my chances you have
won a couple of huge tournaments this
year Greinke classic Norway chess now
you've come here and won this tournament
you're going on to the World Cup and we
also know there's gonna be a special
event for you on September 30th I
believe you're getting married what's
responsible for the resurgence of Levon
Aronian okay pixie dust following you
everywhere well you know starting a new
family requires lots of positive emotion
and also financial support who is who is
better in achieving that person himself
so I I thought it's time to start
playing more seriously and trying to
have better balance comes to creativity
and pragmatic pragmatic approach I
didn't manage in singles Cup but I think
in the blitz I was more or less it blitz
in rapid I was more or less pragmatic at
the right times thank you so much and
once again congratulations everyone to
the winner of the event Levon Aronian
[Music]
[Applause]
and he's on to the money we had a
fantastic player come in third place is
known as a legend in the world of blitz
and he certainly showed his tenacity
despite some hiccups here and there he
was able to bring it home at the very
end and prove why he's indeed one of the
best rapid and blitz players in the
world in third place from the United
States Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura Rex
you may take a photo op Lee our Rex
takes that photo up with that win Hikaru
picked up nine Grantchester points and
also a cool $22,500 for his efforts over
the five days much congratulations to
dakaru for that work coming in second
place he absolutely astounded all of us
with a blistering score seven wins in a
row against this lineup you tell you
that's a tremendous feat he wasn't able
to complete the entire comeback but he
certainly showed us why he is indeed the
world blitz champion from Russia
Grandmaster Sergei car yaki in second
place
[Applause]
Sergei also picks up nine Grantchester
points and $22,500 for his efforts and
I'd like to introduce the Godfather of
chess as his wife always says Rex
Sinquefield to say a few words about the
winner yes okay this was an incredible
exciting event and I want to compliment
and thank all of the players for making
it so exciting and of course the
commentators for adding to that
excitement all over the world Maurice
already referred to the amount of
viewership we had thanks especially to
former world champion Garry Kasparov I
was told today that on one sight alone
today
we had a million viewers that's one
sight and they're like five or six or
ten different sites that cover this
event it'll be interesting to hear from
fleischman-hillard what the total
impressions are that we have in this
tournament last year the Sinquefield Cup
this is measured by radio programs TV
programs articles written etc they
estimate how many people could have
heard about this or read that article or
saw that show last year the Sinquefield
cup had 670 billion impressions
worldwide and I think we're going to
pass that I'm hoping we reach a trillion
so and now it's and what a great winner
what a great friend he's he's got to be
the comic genius of chess the winner of
the st. Louis rapid blitz grandmaster
Levon Aronian
and for his win LaVon picks up 13 grand
chest tour points as well as $37,500 for
his fine performance Levon continues and
simply absolutely fantastic year so far
he'll be moving on to the World Cup
where we try to qualify for the
candidates to play against Magnus
Carlsen and he also will be getting
married what a nice cap to close out
what has been an incredible 2017 it
could not have happened to a nicer
person LaVon is much deserving thank you
so much
[Applause]
well the summary of chances come to a
close I've been here since July 26
calling these three events back to back
to back I got to say I love st. Louis
but I'm happy to be going home that will
be Brooklyn New York and it has been an
absolutely great year I tell you the
reason why we do good commentary I won't
say what Rex said about the best
commentary team in all of sports but the
reason why we enjoyed so much is because
we enjoy each other and my team Yaser
and jan and christian korilla and
everyone who contributed to the rest of
the broadcast it's because we're having
such a good time and it's because these
great players give us the kind of chests
that make us gasp in shock sometimes and
stare in admiration they are indeed the
gods of chests and they will continue to
play brilliant games that make us all so
happy and I'm happy now to say goodbye
Rex I just my teammates an ultimate
moves for not yelling at me too harshly
I'm sure I deserved it well I'm sure
Andy doesn't want to be reminded of what
happened in ultimate moves but it's time
to say goodbye but that's just for now
because there will be more chess to come
certainly London with the London chess
classic will have the final event of the
year
we will once again have the great
players magnus carlsen Wesley soul
Maxine by Sheila Grove Michael Adams
will join the fray as well as some of
these players you see here and it will
be a tremendous event to close out the
year there's a race between Magnus and
mvl Maxime uh Sheila Grove
I believe Aronian has also stepped into
the frame mathematically as well he
needs a little bit of help so I think
he's he's hoping the other players beat
up on Magnus and Maxime by Sheila Graham
but it will be an exciting event for
sure we will be bringing it to you
of course here live from the Chess
eleven scholastic centre of st. Louis
and online at Grantchester or.org
everyone thank you so much for your
fandom for your tweets for your
questions your call ends and we'll see
you in a few months
thank you so much and have a great night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]